[Musique]
je me présente je suis paul et je suis
étudiant en 4ème année à lessines
l'école d'ingénieurs du pôle léonard de
vinci
aujourd'hui je suis là pour vous
raconter mon histoire l'histoire de mon
ressenti pendant la crise sanitaire donc
cette histoire c'est facile elle
commence pour moi sur scène en tant que
comédien dans une pièce de théâtre
c'était la première fois que je faisais
ça j'étais super content tout se passait
vraiment pour mieux c'était l'un des
plus beaux jours de ma vie je sors on
rallume les téléphones et là je vois sur
mon téléphone cet appel en absence 4 de
ma maman est trop de mon père donc je le
rappelle est en fait on m'explique que
c'est le soir où emmanuel macron annonce
le premier confinement à cause du coc
vie de 19 nous sommes en guerre en
guerre sanitaire certes nous luttons ni
contre une armée ni contre une autre
nation mais l'ennemi et là on se pose
plein de questions à ce moment là on se
demande comment ça va se passer est-ce
que je rentre chez moi à nancy dans ma
famille ou bien est-ce que je reste sur
paris qu'est ce que je fais je l'appelle
ma famille est ce qu'il faut que je
rentre chez moi on me dit maintenant
vous mieux peut-être rester tout seul
sur paris isolé parce qu'apparemment le
virus se propage extrêmement rapidement
et là je me dis on va attendre les
informations de mon école pour savoir
comment ça va se dérouler un peu on
avait déjà eu le cas de figure des cours
en ligne quelques mois avant à cause de
la ratp de la grève de la ratp et les
gilet jaune qui nous avait empêchés
d'aller ans
en cours pendant pendant quelques
semaines donc nous coûter quelque chose
pour lequel ont été relativement bien
habitués mais l'école nous annonce que
semaine annulé suivi d'une semaine de
vacances donc alors là moi je me dis je
suis un peu je suis un peu un gamer un
dico sur les bords je me dis c'est le
bonheur je suis coincé pendant deux
semaines chez moi je suis en vacances
déjà j'avais une solution une semaine de
vacances en plus par rapport à ce qui
est prévu je m'achetais plein de jeux
vidéo et on va tous les faire pendant
les vacances quoi et à ce moment là ça
paraissait comme étant un peu la belle
vie on peut rester coincée chez nous
pendant quelques jours c'est pas si
gênant que ça même si au bout de trois
quatre jours ça a commencé à peser un
peu sur la conscience on commence à
ressentir un peu le manque de vie
sociale du coup on avait trouvé d'autres
moyens on se voyait avec des amis sur
zoom sur discorde on s'appelait assez
régulièrement chapelet régulièrement ma
famille il ya eu la fameuse période des
apéros ou whatsapp ce genre de choses
le confinement a duré beaucoup plus
longtemps que prévu puisqu'il s'est
durement à la base et la durée un peu
près de deux mois
à ce moment là je me suis dit ok ça va
vraiment faire long les gens dans ma
classe sur les groupes de classe on
voyait déjà pendant les cours que
certains étudiants avaient du mal à
suivre parce que bah y avait la famille
qui dérange et il y avait des problèmes
de connexion parce qu'ils étaient à la
campagne mais il ya une sorte d'
entraîne entre les étudiants à ce moment
là il ya un étudiant qui a pas pu su ce
coin là on zoome parce que ben il a eu
un crash internet à ce moment là bas
tant pis on lui file le court on lui
file le replay et puis il le suit un
autre maman et une semaine où j'ai
tellement travaillé que
j'étais totalement désorienté d'un point
de vue des horaires
je savais plus réellement quelque chose
qu'elle heures en été quel jour on était
comme vous le voyez je suis dans un je
vais dans un peu dans un relativement
petit espace et à force de voir personne
en fait on est plus rythmée par rien en
fait on est juste rythmée par nous-mêmes
et du coup on mange dès qu'on a envie de
manger on dort dès qu'on a envie de
dormir et ont travaillé dès qu'on a on
est comme on a envie de travailler
on y retrouvait à manger des repas du
soir à une heure du matin et d'écouté à
midi donc c'était juste pas possible et
là c'est là où ça a commencé à devenir
un peu long
[Musique]
à ce moment là on faisait ça pourra
jamais pierre et au final on verra que
c'était bien que ça
arrive la rentrée est alors l'un la
rentrée le but principal c'était réussir
à faire en sorte que les nouveaux les
nouveaux première année ce bien intégré
parce que personnellement je suis
responsable associatif le but c'est de
leur faire découvrir ce que c'est que la
vie associative étudiante qui grands
pans de la vie étudiante qui a quasiment
pas disparu mais qui tourne un peu au
ralenti et donc on a réussi à le faire
en deux trois semaines et ensuite le
président a annoncé que va y aller avant
un deuxième confinement dès demain midi
et pour quinze jours au moins nos
déplacements seront très fortement
réduit c'est beaucoup d'étudiants ont là
a dit que le deuxième confinement 1a
crise sanitaire avait repris de plus
belle à cause des rassemblements
notamment en étudiant les rêves
participants tout l'été qui ont eu lieu
les soirées dans les petit appartement
et que c'était à cause de ce genre de
chose que le virus avait repris et ça
c'était terrible parce qu'en fait c'est
un réel décrochage entre les étudiants
et la population
il ya eu beaucoup d'étudiants qui ont
fait des dépressions parce que ça
commence à être long des étudiants en
première année qui se sentaient pas
intégré dans l'alcool qui connaissait
personne qui avait pas eu la chance
d'intégrer une association qui avait pas
eu la chance de se faire un bon groupe
d'amis c'est dur c'est dur d'avoir 20
ans 2001
c'est dur donc je donnerais jamais de
leçon à nos jeunes parce que ce sont
ceux qui honnêtement vivent un sacrifice
terrible arrive la période des fêtes
donc à ce moment là je rentre à nancy de
nouveau voir ma famille par manque de
chance du coup gt gt j'étais chez ma
mère est en fait elle a chopé le coc
vide à ce moment-là pile poil 2 jours
avant noël
et ont du coup je me suis retrouvé
confinés pendant la défaite chez moi
dans ma chambre parce que cas contacts
et alors j'ai passé je pense le noël le
plus triste de ma vie puisque bas
c'était c'était terrible parce que pas
de repas de fête chacun dans sa chambre
et on regarde netflix quoi et il y avait
une chose que j'attendais c'était nouvel
an parce que on avait prévu de faire une
petite soirée même si c'était pas
conseillé on s'était dit voilà on a
quand même dans l'ensemble bien tous
respecter les différents confinement on
s'est pas vu on s'était fait tester
avant
du coup à nouvel an tu es une petite
dizaine d'autres comme ça et donc là
c'était vraiment une espèce de bouffée
d'oxygène de
donc on arrive en janvier et alors là il
ya un phénomène
presque d'amplification de la crise
étudiante qui était déjà bien présentes
avant notamment à cause du fait qu' on a
réouvert les écoles on a réouvert les
écoles primaires on a réouvert les
crèches les maternelles les collèges les
lycées et les universités on ne les a
pas pour tout de suite et c'était
vraiment l'incompréhension de bas
pourquoi on ré ouvre des lieux ou des
enfants de 3 à 15 18 ans peuvent
respecter le geste barrières et après on
part du principe que bâle et les adultes
de 18 à 25 ans ils peuvent plus
respectées en plus de centres de coûts
qui sont quand même relativement grand
et à l'espace ya plein d'endroits pour
manger le risque c'était con ce qu'on se
retrouve beaucoup plus souvent dans des
appartements étudiants qui sont beaucoup
plus petits du coup la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur a pris la
décision de commencer à ouvrir les
universités pour les premières années
ensuite ça aurait ouvert progressivement
aux années supérieures et je me souviens
que le premier jour où j'ai je suis
retourné en cours en présentiel c'était
c'était assez impressionnant parce que
je me suis
assez bizarre je sais des gens fous
vraiment je voyais pour la première fois
avec des gens même avec qui il avait
travaillé en groupe avait créé fait le
travail de groupe de plusieurs semaines
et tout d'un coup bah tiens t'es là je
crois que le premier cours que j'ai eues
en présentiel j'ai rarement été aussi
productif à l'école de toute ma vie
les étudiants quant à eux pourront pour
ceux qui le souhaitent continuer durant
toute cette période à se rendre à
l'université pour une journée de cours
par semaine et puis arrive le troisième
confinement et à ce moment là
personnellement
j'ai eu un petit passage à vide je pense
qu'on a tous eu un passage à vide qui a
durée plus ou moins longtemps c'était
fini les cours en présentiel
c'était fini de pouvoir voir des gens un
peu un extérieur en fait c'est là où
j'ai un peu pris conscience que bah oui
je suis en 4e année c'est la fin de mai
c'est presque la fin de mes études il me
reste plus qu'à 1 puisque plus plus
qu'un an et au final sur toutes mes
études j'ai eu deux ans en prépa pendant
lesquels j'ai quand même profiter puis
ensuite un an où on profite les deux
premiers mois puis la grève de la ratp
pulco vide puis ensuite si à la rentrée
et puis rocco vide j'avais eu une la
sensation de perdre en fait d'avoir
perdu presque de vraiment deux années de
ma vie
ben voilà on a perdu de deux ans en fait
c'est dur c'est dur d'avoir 20 en 2008
c'est dur
[Musique]
la perception de la crise sanitaire par
les étudiants pouvaient être différente
d'un étudiant un autre puisqu'il ya des
étudiants qui peuvent aller bien comme
une étudiante ils peuvent aller pas bien
il ya des étudiants qui n'étaient pas
bien et qu'ils vont bien maintenant et
inversement c'est pour ça que j'ai fait
le choix de vous raconter mon histoire
mon témoignage ma perception actrice
d'étudiante et pas celle de quelqu'un
d'autre
[Musique]